la polémica llega a la Corte Suprema de
Estados Unidos el medio sin fines de
lucro pública divulgó el jueves un
extenso reportaje en el que se refleja
que Clarence Thomas uno de los
magistrados del más alto tribunal
estadounidense habría aceptado viajes de
lujo por parte del donante millonario
del partido republicano harland desde
república sostienen que la frecuencia de
los regalos al juez no tiene precedentes
conocidos en la historia moderna de la
Corte Suprema los obsequios del Magnate
de Dallas de Thomas incluyen viajes a
bordo de yates y jets privados sin
embargo el magistrado publicó un
comunicado en el que sostiene que hizo
todo acorde a la Norma y el millonario
declaró que con sus regalos nunca trató
de influir en las decisiones judiciales
de su amigo a principios de mi mandato
en la corte busqué la orientación de mis
colegas y otras personas en el poder
judicial y me informaron que este tipo
de hospitalidad personal de parte de
amigos personales cercanos que no tenían
asuntos ante la Corte no tenían que ser
informados siempre he tratado de cumplir
con esas pautas que ahora se están
cambiando ya que el comité de la
conferencia judicial responsable de la
divulgación financiera para todo el
poder judicial Federal anunció el mes
pasado nuevas normas y tengo por
supuesto intención de seguir esta guía
en el futuro desde la Casa Blanca por su
parte evitaron hacer comentarios al
respecto es algo de lo que debe hablar
la Corte Suprema Simplemente no voy a
comenzar sobre esto en este momento cree
que el congreso debe actuar es algo que
el congreso debe discutir solo digo que
no voy a comentar sobre esto en este
momento la nueva Norma que aplica sobre
los miembros del poder judicial desde el
pasado mes obliga a jueces de la Corte
Suprema y de los juzgados federales a
declarar todo tipo de viajes y obsequios
con objeto de mejorar la transparencia
de las instituciones